So I think my experience has been that
human beings are hard wired to receive things in
story form. So if you can craft a narrative
behind what you are doing, it makes it easy
to, it makes it it makes it more compelling.
And you know, it doesn't have to be you
know, like a coming of age story or anything
like that. It could simply be like like there
was this problem, there exists this problem. Here's
what people previously did, here's why it's not any
good. We did this, here's what we found
and like that's the end. So there's this sort
of like there's this narrative arrow that goes
through it. and, so that's one and number 2,
I guess the other tip that I would have
is think about your audience. Who is your audience?
Are your audience is your audience technically oriented, or
are they not technically oriented? Is your goal basically, is
your, are you trying, is it a bunch of
people that you're trying to recruit to come and join
you, in which case maybe you want to show
them like cool demos. Or are they you know, just
just like a, a room full of your hard-nosed science
colleagues who are just going to brutally scrutinize whatever you present
to them in which case, you may want to do something else.